You. So thank you. Thank you. We'll now move into
the patient, overly patient It
department, as we are now
officially 55 minutes over.
But I'm sure Director Kent will make up for that 55
minutes of lost time.
Am I on?
So, good afternoon. Good afternoon.
As mayor pro Tim Martin indicated, I am Lisa Kent.
I am the city's chief information officer and the director
of the Houston It. Services Department.
With me. Here is William Bryant. William was introduced
first by Director Emo. He is the department fiscal
Administrator assigned to Hits. He is a member of the finance organization.
Will serves in a CFO like function for my
department. And I also want to acknowledge the two financial
analysts that support Will. One of them is here today. That's herbert Gardner.
He's raising his hand back there. And the other one is Curia askew. She's out
of the office today, so she's not present. So together,
this team of three helps manage a very large
and complex budget for the Hits department. And I want
to thank them for helping me prepare this presentation and all the data associated
with it. I also want to give a huge shout out to the Hits executive
team. They are not here. They are busy working on all the projects that
support you and our customers. But I will acknowledge them
in the next few slides and give you a little flavor for what they
do in our organization. Many of you, in fact,
most of you, have met all of my direct reports and know
them from either Cyber or TTI presentations.
And I know you know how proud I am of them, each one of them
personally, as well as for the professional work that they do for the city of
Houston each and every day. So with that, let's get started, and we'll go
to the next slide.
So the proposed fiscal year 23 budget for Hits
is $98,051,415.
Hits budget is entirely a central services revolving
fund, which means that the funding we spend
is charged back to those departments who consume our services.
And that chargeback shows up in each of those department budgets under
their restricted accounts. Our FY 23
budget includes the funding for 210.6
positions. Please note that the FTE funded account
amount for the previous year FY 22 was 202
positions, with a vacancy factor of around 7.4%.
This FY 23 increase in the funded FTEs
is due to the consolidation of It personnel
from three different departments. So these are not net new
positions. They are positions that are moving from one department into the other.
For FY 23, we did choose to increase our vacancy factor
to approximately 7.77%.
The decision to do that was made in consideration not only of the economic
conditions, but specifically from the
significant challenges that we're encountering in the It market and
that is adversely impacting our ability to recruit
It professionals. You may recall Director Emo
referenced the great resignation in her initial presentation.
This is certainly something that is impacting it everywhere.
It is not a problem that is unique to the City of Houston. I am
a member of the Inspire Houston CIOs group for the
city of the Houston regional area. I regularly
talk and visit with CIOs from all parts of the
business, including private sector, and every single one
of us is facing this challenge. And so this is something that is
not unique to City of Houston government.
Looking department wide below that first chart.
This body of the slide shows the distribution of funds and personnel across
seven key areas within our department. You can see the breakdown of
budget and personnel for each of those areas. I'm not going to read this chart,
but it's there for your reference. So, next slide.
Now let's go through those key functions. I'm going to do this quickly in
a more abbreviated fashion than I would normally have done. But I do want
to start out that at the Director's office level, as the CIO for the City
of Houston, I am responsible for It strategic planning
and It governance. In addition to that, we have the amazing
Dr. Jane Wu, who is assistant director for our Resource Management
division. She's responsible for those additional functions underneath.
Next, the cybersecurity team is led by the city's Chief Information
Security Officer, who is another incredibly talented
and powerful leader. That's Dr. Christopher Mitchell. And yes,
we do have two PhDs as part of my Direct Reports team.
We're very proud of that. Chris is responsible for those
things that you see listed below. I do want to emphasize that
for FY 23, we will be beginning our efforts to develop the
next four year Master plan. And the focus of that going
forward will be building an infrastructure with a zero
trust model. And so council member Cayman in
advance. I know you're going to be asking the question, what are ways that you
guys can support us or unmet needs? We are always going
to ask for additional support and additional funding for our
cybersecurity program. So you'll hear more from us
in the private briefings that we address with you and where we educate
you a little bit on what we're facing and what we're doing about it.
Transitioning to Enterprise infrastructure services. The Deputy CIO
position for this functional area is currently vacant.
However, we are very blessed to have two strong and capable leaders
underneath that vacant position. And so those two groups are
the network and telecom services group, led by Assistant Director Anthony Evigan
and the Compute services, led by Assistant Director Burke
Corford. This is our largest organization, as you can see
from the Plier side, both on dollars and on positions.
And so you can take a look later at all the amazing
things that they do and to keep the city running.
Next slide.
Next is Public Safety Communications, and this is led by a very
strong technical leader, and that is Assistant Director Nick Curran,
one of the things that's not listed in this description. So just a feel for
scale. We support over 18,000 radios
within the city of Houston. Those are largely police and fire. They're a
combination of handheld or portable radios in addition
to the in car or mobile radios.
Besides those 18,000, we also support 6600
radios, for which we sell those services to more
than 30 greater Houston regional partners.
And then these last three programming areas are all led by Summer Shao.
Summer is one of the real transformational forces on our
Direct Reports team. We couldn't do our job
without her and her capable folks. She is responsible for
those. Next three. I'm not going to read each one of them, but I will
point out that Enterprise Application
Services encompasses ERP, which Council Member Kubosh,
I know you sometimes ask me about acronyms that is essentially Enterprise
Resources Management and Planning is our SAP platform.
So that's our financial procurement and HR system.
That group also includes data management, enterprise,
GIS, analytics and so forth. And then client management
solutions. Those are CSMART. That's the courts
where my team maintains the system that Judge Marshall's organization
uses to operate her business. And then finally we have the Hits
It Project Management Group, which works on project governance,
scope development metrics, and so forth to help us ensure that those projects
meet the expected outcomes. Next slide.
So there aren't any direct statutes that require us to implement
specific electronic systems. However, all of the city
departments that you hear from depend on Hits in order to
implement their business, and many of them do have statutory
requirements to conduct certain services. These three
cyber statutes listed below, I'm not going to go through each one of them,
but I know that you recognize HIPAA and PCI and security
sensitive information that affects our airport system. Next slide.
In terms of societal impact, again, all city
departments depend on us. We have several stats listed there
that you can read through that give you a feel for the scale of what
we support. At the bottom of the chart, I did list
just a few examples of citizen facing services,
and we had planned to share some statistics with you. I can get those to
you offline if you're interested. But Council Member
Kubosh, one of those was infor, as a matter of fact, for dawn statistics
about how much they use that platform for.
Next slide. So let's talk about funding.
This is the second fiscal year that Hits is budgeted completely
in the revolving fund. Therefore, all of our expenses
are revolved back or charged back to the city department customers.
The chargeback is seen as an expense again in their restricted
accounts, but it's offsetting as revenue for my department. And so therefore,
this table that you see on this chart represents
a revenue table, and it matches the expenditures table that
you'll see on the next slide. These amounts will always be the same. We have
to zero out our budget at the end of the year.
Thank you. So the revenue highlights.
Again, most of our revenue comes back, but here's a couple of unique revenues
that we generate that you might not know about. The first is the Verizon Wireless
Rebate in FY 22. Actual revenues already
collected is a million dollars. Of that,
794,000 went to the General Government
Revenue Fund, 43,000 went to the Houston Airport
System and 163,000 went to Houston Public
Works. Another cool revenue source is that radio revenue that
I talked about. That will be $1.9 million
by the time we end this fiscal year. And again, that is
booked to the city's general Revenue Fund. Next slide.
So, expenditures. This chart represents a historical view of our
expenditures. The variance column over to the right,
second to last, shows you the comparison of FY 23 to FY
22 adopted budget. As you can see, that variance is
10.8% and I'll go into some details about that on
the next slide.
So the overall proposed budget we are submitting again is 98,051,000
in change. Of that only 31% is for personnel.
69% of our budget is for services and supplies
that provide those products and services to other departments.
The pie chart on the right is that nonpersonal breakdown. That 69%.
And so one thing that's important to note over the past few years we've
made significant progress in benchmarking our expenses to similar
It organizations of like size and function.
And so one of the things that you'll notice in this presentation is we are
using those same categories that align with the Gartner It budget
tool that we use for benchmarking. I'll start with this chart
with traditional software and I'll move clockwise around that
particular chart. Traditional software makes up 24%
of our expenditures and that represents software that is installed physically
on our equipment in our data centers. The next one is
SaaS or Software as a service that makes up 16%.
And SaaS is an example of a vendor provided and maintained product
in the cloud. An example would be Office 365.
The next 15% includes expenses related to education,
training and supplies to support our operations.
The next one is transport. Transport portion represents 21%
and that is projected expenses for mobile, fixed data and
voice services, citywide pass
or platform as a service along with other public cloud.
And Is which is infrastructure as a service. Those represent
a combined 2% and they are public cloud management
and security services. In simpler terms,
those are the things where we use a vendor's infrastructure and that is shared
so that we get improved economies of scale and flexibility
for scaling up and scaling down very quickly. Examples of that would
be Azure or Amazon Web Services.
Next. The 17% is allocated to traditional outsourcing
and they are the fees that we pay for consultants and managed
services where we may hire a company to do a service for us
like communications, cabling or portions
of our telecom infrastructure. And then the final category is 5% for
hardware. One important point to note on that,
we do buy a lot of hardware through our capital improvement budget. So it's
not surprising that hardware is a lower percentage in the operating budget.
Next slide.
Now I would like to highlight some of the net changes in
the proposed FY 23 budget over FY 22.
The first item you will see again that we are consolidating
resources. Five of those FTEs are
coming from the Houston Health Department in the infrastructure
area. Three are from Houston Public Works. That is
part of our consolidation of cybersecurity for that department.
Those are moving under dr. Chris Mitchell. And then the last
one is in Legal, a partial consolidation. And those
folks that one individual physician is moving under our infrastructure team.
So together these combined are 1.34 million.
Again moving into my department from another department.
Secondly, you can see the hope increases for approximately 846,000
increase over last year's budget. Next you'll see
two net new initiatives. Those expenditure lines have been
submitted for approval to the administration. These dollars
support the maintenance of our open data portal and also
new radio security services which is going to help us
protect our radio system from malicious
software and other malicious activity.
And finally, the restricted accounts for Hits consist of allocations
Hits receives from other departments such as Ara,
Human Resources, Finance and Planning. So in summary, we have
a 10.8% increase. I will highlight
the key portions of that increase on the upcoming slide.
So I won't go over it consolidation again, but I
will move down to some of what you'll see in our budget is a realignment
of expenses. So for example, Director Emo referenced
Hits is the pilot department. We are always
up for a challenge and being the guinea pig for the city to try things
first. And so as part of that initiative, we went through and looked at one
of the areas we needed to separate from one cost center into
two was our end user Compute support services. So that's just
dividing those into two cost centers and that will also help
us with cleaner chargeback. Another example of Realignment
is in the data management area. This is another one council member Kubosh
asked me about. We hired the Edo,
which is the Enterprise data Officer his name is Raphael Luvre.
And when we did that hire,
we did realign the expenses of the resources that now
can report up under that separate cost center for those functions.
I also want to point out that the hiring of the Edo
helped us as a city accomplish one of the actions
required by the Resilient Houston plan. That's action number 44.1.
And then finally on Realignments we are also adjusting
costs between Esignature and managed print services.
So in further support of Resilient Houston and the climate action plan.
We are driving print costs down and we are
encouraging an increased usage of Esignature.
So more electronic processing, less printing
transitioning. Let's talk about Microsoft.
Last August, Microsoft announced that they would
be rolling out a substantive price increase across the
board to all Office 365 subscribers.
That's global. Okay? We were grandfathered in. That's why it
did not affect my budget in FY 22. We were still under the
current Enterprise agreement where the pricing was locked.
However, next month I will be coming to the TTI committee to
present to you the proposed new three year enterprise agreement for
the city and that will incorporate the price increase
as well as an upgrade in features that we will be requesting. So you'll
hear a lot more from me about what's involved in those prices.
But just a little preview, that's part of what is
included in our FY 23 budget. And then
next, we've already discussed a little bit about the job market and the great resignation.
One of the things that we had to include in our budget for FY 23,
we noticed the most significant attrition in our ERP group.
Again, that's our SAP support function. And so
we did submit as part of our budget to augment that ERP
team. That addresses the concern that we're having not
only with retirement and attrition, but the difficulty
in the extended periods of time it's taking us to recruit, to backfill.
And then finally in the cybersecurity insurance sector,
this continues to diminish as more providers
vacate that space. That results in an increase
in premiums and it also results
in a reduction of coverage. And so that's something that you will
hear more from us about in some of the private briefings. And so there
you have it. That is a summary of the FY 23 expenditure
changes. This concludes my presentation.
I do want to invite you to browse through the appendix. There are
a lot of documents back there that talk about not only our organization,
but also our strategic priorities, challenges with technological
debt, and our FY 22 accomplishments. So with
that, I'll be glad to take your questions. Thank you, Director Kent.
Council Member Michael Kubosh. Thank you very much, Director Kent.
I appreciate your biweekly report for the Open
Finance. The cybersecurity that you
have us take online is extremely helpful
to people like me that I wasn't
born with a mouse in my hand. So I've learned a
lot from those cyber security courses.
I appreciate you giving us advanced notice on rates
and rate increases and things that we have to purchase because it used to just
give this council shell shock when we'd see these things
appear. Do we get federal grants to help
us to pay for cybersecurity? Is there anything available
that may help us to mitigate the cost of some of these things?
Yes, sir. We do get federal grant money through UASI,
and that is granted through the City's Department
of homeland Security under Chief Eunuch.
What we get from them is largely training.
We do seek to get more money, and we have been lobbying
federal legislatures,
legislators, to help us have the federal
government release more cybersecurity money to actually buy product
and services. Now, I do expect to see that
in some of the new federal bills. We have not yet seen it
trickle down, but you might see that in the infrastructure bill once it's finally announced.
I would like to see updated times where you give us this mandatory
cybersecurity training because I think it's
really needed and I really do appreciate it. Thank you.
Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman. Thank you,
Mayor. Pro TEM director. I think you know where my
questions are going to be, are going to go towards but I think it's
startling. A lot of the budget presentations we see personnel
is the major cost. You don't see that with it.
I think that's two things, but correct me if I'm wrong. One, we don't
have a lot of personnel in the department. I work with Dr.
Mitchell and you a lot. I don't know how he does everything that he does.
He is incredible. But it's also the cost
of this type of equipment, the technological cost,
that, again, a lot of it's behind the scenes, but it's
necessary to keep the city safe.
I know that we cannot in a public realm discuss a lot as
it relates to Homeland Security concerns,
cyber concerns, but we have seen some of the more public
hacks and things like that that have occurred. For example, Kronos was
something that actually didn't impact us as much as it did other
businesses, but still had an impact that wasn't against city infrastructure.
But given the current
dynamics, the war in Ukraine, other issues,
where are we as a city, just generally speaking, in terms
of coming into moving beyond the last century,
in terms of technology upgrades here?
Thank you for asking that question. I will give you a
measured response. We can provide
and do provide a lot of detailed information to you,
city council members, and obviously to Mayor Turner
that are very specific about what the city
faces from a cybersecurity perspective.
What I will say publicly is that
with your support, we have been making tremendous
strides. One of the things that you will see spoken
about publicly with anyone talking
about cybersecurity is the need for a layered
defense strategy. And so no matter
which entity you talk to, government or private sector alike,
they will all tell you we're always going to need to do
more. Okay? And so what we need
you to understand is much to Council Member Kubosh's
comment, that it takes everybody, it takes the employees to
be security conscious, and it takes us to put
many layers of defense in there simply to have a fighting
chance at slowing down the adversary. I could be put back
in queue. Go ahead,
last one. You're the only one. All right, I'll hurry up because I know people
want a quick break for lunch, if we can. Not yet,
no, keep driving.
I was just at a roundtable conversation this morning
with FEMA. So we're talking about the federal dollars that
we need to draw down upon. And we were talking with different
colleagues around the country about what keeps us up at night,
and cybersecurity redundancy is what keeps me up
at night. But also,
Council Member Peck and I talk a lot about this other council members,
our CAD system, other needs that are just
so high in terms of price tag that we as
a city cannot afford without those investments. We have CAD.
That is a need. Are there other needs that we should be aware of right
now as it relates to those It
assets that we can speak about publicly?
Yes. If you would flip to page 20,
which is in the appendix section. There's a chart there that gives you a
feel for the scale. When we talk about
technical debt or technological debt, we're talking
about systems that no different than
what Director Haddock spoke about with her infrastructure for
water and sewer. The city has infrastructure,
both hardware and software applications that we have to maintain.
And when you don't replace those often enough,
you create a vulnerability, which translates
to risk. Those equipments either get old and
they don't function as well as they used to, or they are
no longer supported by the manufacturer. And therefore, that translates into a cyber risk.
So this chart, that's worth looking at. If you look on the right hand side
of the page, it shows you what our five year citywide
CIP is. The only thing not included in that is the Houston
Airport systems. Separate CIP and Houston Public Works.
Separate CIP. But otherwise, that number of 39,000,500
is the five year number for years 22
through 26 for capital investment in technology.
The left hand side of the column is only the top six
projects that we need funding for.
Really? Four and a half of those six are public safety
technology related. So in terms of what is needed,
the city needs more spending capacity
to deal with public safety technology equipment.
And the ones that I've listed there are HPD Radio refresh,
the HPD Records Management System network refresh,
which I'm saying is partially public safety related CAD,
which you just asked about $17 million. The only
one that is wholly not public safety related is the SAPS
for Hana upgrade. But at the
top, there is CSMART, where we need to do some continued technology
refresh. And that does have some public safety implications with that
system as well. So these monies, you can tell
the dramatic skewing of what's available
versus what is needed just for the top six.
No, and I appreciate that highlight. And just for those in
the public that are listening, when we talk about records Management systems
with HPD. That sounds very basic, but there's certain data that
we cannot even track right now, including when a
crime involves a gun, whether that gun was stolen,
whether it was obtained legally. We cannot track
any of that right now, even though we're dealing with astronomical
levels of gun violence. So all these basic things, right, that we think as
a city we should be able to do, we are having challenges with.
So I just appreciate your department.
Again, so much of it goes back to Public Safety. I don't
know how you do and your team do all the things that you do do,
but recognizing the budgetary
limitations that we are continuing to face right now. Thank you.
So, Director Cant, one thing struck me and one thing only in your budget.
So 22 to 23, you have an
interdepartmental credit
for 1.3 million. Without that, you're 34 million
less than what you spent last year.
Right. So you had 88 you -1.3 you're
at 98. Because you had interdepartmental
consolidations of FTE. Can you put some color around that?
Because I look at it and I go at 1.34 million.
That's 18 employees at $75,000.
So I'm assuming we're going to see the appropriate
debit from Public Works, which we
didn't see because I just looked through their notes.
Legal and HHD,
you're getting the people, but the flow of funds isn't following you.
It is following you. But the appropriate debit isn't coming out of their department's
expense. That's right. Because they continue to pay for those resources
that are dedicated to them. So what is a little bit confusing
about we added 1.3 to your budget on the increase.
Yes. What is confusing about the way the revolving funds
work is the money has to be on both sides of the fence.
So for me to have the control of those positions
and the money to fund them, it has to show up in my revolving
fund budget. It also has to show up on their side of the
house in their restricted account. And so when I charge them back,
it goes back. So I'm looking for I see your credit
of 1.3. I don't see their debit of 1.3 or whatever theirs
is for their individual department, but their debit will be in
their restricted account. In the restricted account. So all of
our expenses are budget within the department's restricted accounts.
So that slide where like on our slide number
15, where you have a list of all the inner fund restrictive accounts,
we would charge them back. Okay. Why are you assuming I'm
going to say 75,000. That's 18 people. Why are you assuming
18 people into your department? What's going on?
We're not assuming 18 individuals who we're absorbing nine,
plus their hope increases. Okay, so you're absorbing
their salary? Yes, only their salary, but not their
reporting accountability. We're absorbing their reporting
reporting structure as well. So who do they report to? Do they report
to hits. Yes. In fact, that's one of the reasons why we
do that, because if we leave the money exclusively in their budget,
where they have the ability to choose to spend it on something else,
I love the fact that your department is
more of a centralized function. I hate decentralized function organizations.
That's a massive screw up. You're just waiting for some bad
things to happen. So I'm a big fan of what you did. Okay, great.
Because I believe they should be reporting to you even though they're housed in another
department. But I just wanted to see where they corresponded.
Like Mayor Turner says, hey, you can raise the budget,
but tell me where you're going to get the money. Well, you raised your money
by 1.3 million, and you didn't tell me where
it came from, because I looked back on one of the departments that already presented.
The other two are later, and they didn't have the corresponding debit.
It's restricted. So we'll ask Legal and we'll ask
Houston Health when they come. So. Thank you, council Member Sally Alcorn.
Are there some other departments that you think would benefit from being
consolidated in, or have you swept everybody in that you need to?
We definitely have that's a loaded question.
There are definitely opportunities, and some of those opportunities are
already in discussion with those directors. I wouldn't want to say
that publicly, but there are definitely opportunities for
that. Yes. Great. Thanks. You all
do a great job. Thank you. Day in and day out. I appreciate what you
do. I'm sorry. We have four public
speakers. We'll start out with Mr. Doug Smith,
star six. Doug,
can you hear me? Yes, sir.
Yes. Okay, good. To follow up on the last comment,
relative to are you going to when you look through
the budget, you see lots of departments that have what I would call hit
related expenses, and I guess you're in the process of trying to
sweep all of those in as much as possible. One that
just came from this morning is Houston Public Works. They show $20 million
for computer related expenses. So I'm glad to hear you're in the process
of trying to rope everybody in. And one final question.
Why did the salary for HFD support account
50 00:10 increased by 50%?
And also regarding that, do you provide any kind of similar support
to the Houston Police Department? Okay.
Mr. Smith, the reason why you see the increase in the HFD personnel once we've
gone through the exercise of looking at the EIS
compute call center, basically, we took those individuals that were dedicated
to HFD and moved those to the HFD call center.
So that's why you see that increase in personnel. So the support
level has not changed, but we did move the position,
so therefore the dollars will be in the correct funding structure.
Okay. Do you do similar support for Houston Police Department as well?
No, we. Do not.
The Houston Police Department is what we consider to
be a Federated It organization, which means they have
a Chief Technology Officer and a sizable It organization.
So what my department provides to HPD are the Enterprise
services, which is a whole lot of things,
but there are many services that they still do themselves out
of that technology budget. So they will have both a restricted
account chargeback from my department as well as
a separate It budget for their own. Thank you.
Mr. Why do they have a mr. Oliver. Jason Oliver.
Thanks for interrupting. Thank you.
Hi. Thank you all for the presentation.
The budget was amended last year, item 6.34,
to include an online portal for people to sign up
for public session. I wanted to check in on if that has
been implemented or if we can get a target completion
date.
We were just conferring, Mr. Oliver. I'm not sure that that
particular amendment was actually approved, but what I can tell
you, we do have a project underway that is currently in the
planning phase. It won't be implemented until later in FY 23,
but that is to upgrade the system that the city council uses
for City council agenda. And so our thought is
that we would be using that same platform to allow the digital sign
up of speakers. Now, one thing in addition to that that we
have also been doing is to utilize tool sets that
we already have to encourage the city secretary's office to leverage
things like teams and SharePoint that as people sign up.
That can be done on those existing tools, but we do have plans
to enhance it for the future. Okay, and then can you share
more about what on page eleven, the open
data portal support means, and then how often we can expect to
see updates in the future? I also want to say thank you all.
After last year, you all updated and
made the open data portal accessible again, which was really appreciated.
So thank you for that. We're just checking in about what that means. So you
just answered my question, your own question. So we were having a lot of problems
with that open data portal where, if you may recall, it would go offline.
That is a legacy application that we needed some additional support.
And so the money that we built in as an ad to our budget was
to outsource that additional support until we could simply redesign
it. So the redesign of that open data portal is planned for FY 23 as
well. Thank you. Doing that support I'm
sorry, who's offering that support? How is
that working? I don't recall the name of the vendor off the
top of my head. I can get back to you offline about that, but it
is a vendor consultant that is assisting us with that. Got you.
Thank you, Ms. Planning. As Ms. Planning walks up, so are we moving away
from Novus there is a
project to upgrade Novus. So what the solution will
be is yet to be determined whether it continues to be
the evolution of Novus or another product. Thank you.
Hey, thank you for your presentation. Lots of helpful
explanations in there. I have two questions for you. I noticed almost
60% of the top technological needs you
listed, I believe it was in the appendix, belong to HPD improvements.
And I was curious as to how these priorities were made, especially after you explained
that HPD kind of has their own It.
And then what are other priorities that aren't listed that you would consider
a high priority? And then the second question is management
consulting services has increased dramatically from last fiscal
year, now 3 million from about 1 million. And what is the
reason for that jump? Okay, so Will
is going to help keep me straight on the questions in order, but let's talk
first about this chart, the technological debt. Okay,
so HPD participates along with
all the other city departments, excluding airports and
public works in the citywide, technology, CIP.
So these are all investments that would be capital projects and
they are a part of that solution pool or the group that considers
those. The considerations for why are
these systems on the list and why are they priority one, safe Houston and
public safety is clearly Mayor Turner's top priority.
And one of the things that we look at when we evaluate the
prioritization of It spend is where there is risk.
And in these cases, these equipment, these systems are all end of life
and they pose risk to the city and the police department.
Thank you, Mr. Butler.
I don't know how to get back to her.
Okay.
Hi, good afternoon. I think you guys do an excellent job. I've just got
a series of questions I'll use in my three minutes and then you can respond.
Can you rank your top three priorities?
And you did to finish up that conversation you just started that give
you the best return on investment, dollar wise for every dollar you
spend? The next question is basically,
how are you guys going to do more with less? Because that's the way you've
painted this picture. It's impressive. I just want to know how you're going to do
the magic trick. The other question is, has the city's
IDT department been affected by the pandemic and the supply
chain in slowing down or hindering either major upgrades
or rollouts or updates that you have?
Also, you said you do travel and connect with other cities. Does the
city of Houston rank statewide, regionally and nationally
well and does your budget reflect managing city the
size of Houston? And lastly, very broad question,
how has it priority shifted for you and why?
May I start to answer those? I don't think I can get to all of
them. Okay, so can you give us Readers
Digest version? Okay, so question
number one top three priorities based on ROI. We definitely
focus on things that pose risk, because if we don't deal with those,
they present themselves as much larger, much more expensive problems
to fix after the fact. Okay, so cyber is a great example, but so is
aging equipment. The next one, how are we going to do more
than with less? That is a big challenge.
Thankfully, we hire people who like challenges.
But in terms of getting the best bang for
the buck, we look to identify solutions and
platforms that solve multiple problems. And so you will see
us identifying, particularly in the areas of applications that can
meet multiple departments needs. We talked about infor earlier.
We have several departments using that permitting and inspection platform.
Supply chain? Yes. It's a huge problem. There are certain
pieces of equipment. I won't name the manufacturer, but we have
been waiting for things that normally we would get in one to two months is
taking more than a year. It's a huge problem.
Priority shift. How have my priorities
shifted since the Pandemic? We have
definitely been pushing city departments to accelerate
their digital transformation. One of the things I'm very proud of from
the city's infrastructure standpoint, and even
our applications portfolio, many of those tools
were already there. What we needed to do is help departments
with the business transformation to be able to really embrace operating
digitally all the way to the end. Customer out in the field.
Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you. And that concludes
this part. And, Director Ken, as your neighbor of mine, my son came over
and messed up my printer. So can you come over later on?
I'll see what I can do.